(dramatic music)
(applause)
Fernando: Good evening.
It's a special honor
for me to be here
at National Geographic
because probably
if I was born again
I would give it a try
to be part of this organization.
My poor kids, all my life
whenever we went on vacation,
once they told my
little daughter said,
"Dad, why do we always end up
in the boondocks?" (laughter)
Because the passion
to go to the jungle,
to go to the countryside,
to go see nature
and be close to it
was close to my heart.
I had the pleasure and honor
to meet Bill Garrett
when he was editor
of the magazine.
I went to hear him speak at
a university in Honduras.
Had nothing to do
there other than wanted
to go hear him speak,
and we became very good friends
and I enjoyed wonderful
trips with him
to Maya sites and photography
and learned a lot
from Bill Garrett.
He was the founder of this
wonderful organization
incorporated here in Virginia,
La Ruta Maya
Conservation Foundation.
His vision was to
preserve Maya heritage
in different ways.
I took the presidency
of this organization,
and took it to a
different emphasis
and tried to do with
it the best we could
to preserve this
heritage for Guatemalans.
The piece you'll see on screen
is called the Cancuén Panel.
It narrates the history
of the kings of Cancuén,
their heritage, who they fought,
who they captured, and so forth,
a very important
archaeological piece
that the foundation acquired,
and it keeps today
and offers to museums.
This piece has traveled
the world visiting museums,
and we are constantly
putting it on loan
for exhibits locally.
So we promote education
and we are also
trying to archive and
document everything
that the collection has.
These pieces on screen
are vases that were
acquired here in United States,
or received as donations
here in United States
that were sent back home.
The piece here on the
left is very important
because that little
Mickey Mouse guy
with the ears on the bottom
is the glyph for Mirador,
a site in the jungles of
Guatemala, pre-classic site,
and this glass was
used to drink chocolate
by the king when he
was appointed king.
Around the vase it says
who his grandfather was,
who his father was,
who he is, and
today he's appointed
king of Mirador with
the dates of all this.
This is called an ascension cup,
archaeologically
extremely interesting
and extremely valuable.
This piece was donated
by a collector here
in United States.
Pieces very artistic
or archaeologically
very important are
what we are endeavoring
to bring to Guatemalans
through the collection.
We brought a container of pieces
out of United States
in one shipment.
Sophia Paredes,
the executive director
of the foundation,
you can see her smile
on the face because
she was so happy
these pieces were
coming back home.
Bringing pieces
back to Guatemala
is not a simple story.
There's no legislation to
bring them into the country,
so I bumped into
customs with legislation
that treats these
pieces that are
Guatemalan pieces
as merchandise.
They want us to pay duties
when we bring them in.
I raise hell and I
don't pay the duties,
and I find a way to
bring them in (laughter)
because I was so offended
when they told me
that we had to pay duties.
I said, "These are Guatemalans
"coming back to Guatemala.
"You cannot charge us for it."
And I even threatened
to take them back
bring them back to the States.
But the truth is the
fellow from customs
said, "Please don't
be angry with me.
"I just don't have
legislation to back me up,
"and I have to charge the duty."
So I got the Ministry of Culture
to run them through
customs for me,
and they avoided the law and
we did not pay. (laughter)
We did not pay the duties.
We have a law right now
in hands of Congress
that we have worked
and spent quite
a bit of effort to correct this
so we can in the future
import these pieces legally.
In 2012 we bought these
pieces in California.
They were part of a
private collection,
very important pieces.
These are part of a
staircase of La Corona,
a very important site
that archaeologists
were crazy looking for
because they only knew
by reference with other sites
that La Carona existed
and it was finally found.
These pieces, the
companion of these pieces
are in American
museums illegally.
We're going to ask nicely to see
if we can get them back,
and if not, later we will
think of other ways. (laughter)
But these pieces
need to go back.
They left the country illegally.
We can prove that.
We have photographs
of archaeologists
at the site with these pieces.
And the last piece
is very interesting
because it says this king
enjoyed drinking pulque
which is a wine made
out of maize, corn.
So the Maya had a lot
of sense of humor.
Not everything they
put on their stelaes
is very important
information like this one
saying that he was
drinking pulque.
But they're very important
archaeologically for us.
Every piece we have
we invest huge effort
in documenting them.
Our files for every
piece are as good
as any museum here
in the States.
We're very proud of that,
and we are working to
put all these photographs
online, high resolution,
20 megapixel photography.
We're putting them
online as we speak.
Every piece, we
abide by the law,
it's properly registered
with the National Registry
of Antiquities,
and the instant they become
part of that registry,
they obviously are
available to any researcher.
But if a researcher comes to us,
we make the pieces available,
the photography, everything
available for free.
Our collection is
right now 3,300 pieces
that are registered.
Some as I say are
extremely valuable
and very important.
Every museum in the
country has pieces
from our collection.
We focus today on that effort
of documenting and repatriating,
and we have received donations
from Guatemalan collectors,
or international collectors.
One of the most
touching moments for me,
I went to a house of a friend,
gives me a piece and
I am admiring it.
I said, "My, God, this is
really an important piece,"
and I'm putting it
back on the shelf.
He said, "No, no,
no, no. Take it.
"It's for you. It's
for the museum.
"It's for the foundation."
My hair just, you know,
you can imagine the emotion
of receiving that,
and I have a friend
in North Carolina
and he puts in my hands
a mosaic jade mask,
and I'm putting it back.
He says, "No, no. Take
it, but take it fast
"before I change my
mind." (laughter)
And I took it in my
hand and I smuggled
into the country and
it is happily sitting
in a museum in Museo Miraflores
in Guatemala City today.
So this effort
it's controversial.
Some archaeologists
don't like what I do.
I'm very proud of what I do,
and we can have a very
solid discussion about it,
and we can agree to disagree,
but these are public places
where our pieces are exhibited.
They have no place
in a warehouse.
I don't have enough
places to exhibit them,
and we need to create a place,
a world-class place to exhibit.
The Arts Show of Los
Angeles invited us
to exhibit there,
and we presented the
piece in the center there.
It's almost 10 feet long.
It's a monumental piece.
It's a very important
piece we acquired
from a collector.
These pieces today should
be the core of a museum.
These pieces are part
of the collection
like this rattle here
on the left for a child,
or for an instrument for music.
You can see they're really fun
and very beautiful some of them.
For example, this
bust is the only bust
that we know that
comes from Tikal,
very beautiful also.
That piece we
acquired in Florida.
The one on the right
there is another vessel
to drink chocolate.
Maya considered
chocolate very important,
and it says, "Lord
how so and so.
This is his cup for chocolate
just like you have one in
the kitchen that says sugar
and he had one that
says chocolate.
These are really fun
pieces, very beautiful.
This takes us to the big dream.
We want to create a
museum, world-class museum.
We want to replicate the success
of cities in Europe like Bilbao,
and the Museum of
Bilbao that changed
a fairly ugly industrial city
into a cultural destination.
Today Bilbao has 1.1
million tourists a year
it did not receive before.
Bilbao formerly
was a crisis in Spain
this last few years,
because Bilbao was
receiving double or triple
the tourism than the
rest of the country was
because of one museum.
If we can do that for Guatemala,
we can increase the GNP by 1%.
Because the country receives
1.8 million tourists a year,
I think the museum can
bring 600,000 people a year.
The math we do
with the government
one percentage increase
in gross national product
that could be done
through culture
through an
institution like this.
I won't bore you
with the museum,
but that's my big dream today.
I'm dedicating and committing
probably the next 10
or 20 years of my life
that I hope we
can enjoy to bring
a world-class museum dedicated
to the preservation of
this wonderful heritage.
We went to the best
architects of the world,
and we found some
architects in Switzerland.
This is seen from an airplane
view over the museum.
This is the view of
what we intend to build.
It's a 60,000 square
foot building.
It will take quite a bit of
money that we need to raise,
and we're in the
process of that.
The government will
give us the land.
There's a lot more
to talk about that,
but the purpose is conservation.
The purpose is to
bring well-being
to our country through tourism,
and for me one of
the biggest purposes
is to give the Maya
people of my country
a sense of pride
of being Indian,
a sense of pride of being Maya
because there is a huge heritage
to be proud of and
a museum like this
would be built and created
to celebrate that heritage.
So National Geographic
with this invitation
is giving us credibility
for this effort
and for that I
thank you very much.
Thank you.
(applause)
(thoughtful music)